[Music]
and back we still in quarantine
quarantined a number I stopped counting
to a borders book I'm going stir-crazy
it's challenging my damn relationship
you know we out here you know you know
what it is is like I don't have outlet
that's what it is you know no outlet for
me creatively and all that weird energy
that I have I go onto the stage every
night and I [ __ ] let that [ __ ] out
and I don't have it now so I'm just
driving my girl crazy but what it is is
like you know me and my girl we get real
close we're already really close and so
now it's like move it to the next step
so here's a problem though when you like
it's my place so we're here in my place
and you know ie is my place right so
then you know you have your loved one
come over your girl or your guy if it's
a girl if it's your players whatever
just just talk about for me so they come
over it's not their place right but then
when you're trying to take the next step
if I say hey move in then it becomes
also her place but when it's just my
place you know I am an old dog this is
for my girls own mouth I think you just
old dog stuck in your ways and it's true
cuz my girl wants to like straighten up
and like throw [ __ ] away you know do I
need old a scandal you know like I'll
have like old candle things these are
not old yet but like down to the light
like just like just a little bit of wick
laughs and there's some candle laughs
and I'm the kind of guy who's like I can
still like that but then like you know
when you put the match in the [ __ ] gets
all black it looks terrible it's ugly
she wants to throw him away but she just
wants to ability just to be like I want
to throw that away she throws shits away
that's hard for me to like accept it's
hard for me to be like so I'm in that
part of like that's my stuff don't throw
my stuff away but if I'm telling her
move in stay with me you're here it's
your place too then she should be able
to be like yeah well I don't this is
messy and I don't want this [ __ ] up
candle being here anymore so let's do
something about it so you know it's that
kind of thing it's challenging like you
know it's challenging in a relationship
till I go to that next step because you
have to let go of a lot of things and
compromise
so I'm trying to be okay with it but
then so in the kitchen she was
straightening up the kitchen she did
some stuff in the kitchen so I go into
my my fork and spoons and whatever
drawer and I used to have these like
little spoons and I used little spoons
for honey you know that you know cuz you
just want a little bit of honey you know
what I mean and it's a little spoon for
a little bit of honey
she don't throw him away she was like
that's a baby spoon
you don't need oh damn baby spoon you're
not a baby it's like it's not a baby
spoon it's a honeymoon so we gotta do
like a little disagreement about it and
I'm like that's my spoon you know just
throw my stuff away and she's like that
spoon was stupid you know she just
didn't you know and I was like so in the
heat of it you fight over your pride and
your ego and all that stuff and then
like well now that I think back on it
just like who cares it's a dumbass spoon
so I want to get another baby spoon and
I just go get it but you know it just
it's just kind of things this is [ __ ]
challenging right so I know you know
peace out peace peace and love to my
girlfriend she she was right a spoon was
stupid it's gone the dumb candles when
the candles are done though them shits
away like a because you know you think
like okay I'm gonna keep the candle
glass I'm gonna clean the kind of glass
out and we gonna save it for what what
the [ __ ] am I doing with that can't you
know so publicly she's right you know
what I mean she don't watch my podcast
so she never go here that I said she was
right but you know what's going on this
special episode bonus episode midweek
episode because I made some Skype calls
to some of my friends just a couple of
them and I'm gonna keep doing that
frequently you know but I just wanted to
check in with you guys right now you
know on Instagram I do my cooking on
Instagram and I've been trying to that I
picked up a new hobby
during this quarantine it's cooking I
never thought I was a cooker you know so
you know I like following the recipes I
actually like following I get this thing
from Sun basket shout-out to them you
know these [ __ ] on giving me a
sponsorship let's shout out the Sun
basket cuz they send you everything you
need with the instructions the recipe
and you know whatever and then you can
just like easily
you know put it together you know what I
mean and then it's great stuff like
meatballs skewers and you know pork
chops and and I love the little side
dishes like white sweet potatoes with
cabbage and they give you all these
little like recipes and it just makes
you think about like putting together
other things yourself which is something
that I've already done I made like some
white sweet potatoes just on my own the
other day so I'm picking up cooking
which is actually pretty good but one of
the things I want to talk about so I
went to the damn store you know so I
don't know if y'all been out to the
supermarket but this [ __ ] is bananas man
so first of all so I went to Whole Foods
cuz I'm bougie like that and you know
they had first way you gotta wait
outside you know what I mean and so you
got like the social distancing marks on
the ground so they keeping everybody six
feet apart but still trying to stay open
cuz capitalism's gotta continue right so
you got a way to go in you know so then
the ladies you know directing people in
and she's covered up in like an outbreak
hazmat type of [ __ ] very like okay I
don't know if that's really protecting
her but good for her she's got her job
everybody still needs to work it's great
so she you know so you go so we go into
the store and this particular Whole
Foods wasn't empty it wasn't decimated
but it was a little bit like damn you
couldn't find if you were looking for
something specific the [ __ ] might not be
there so you know we found some things
it was like you know I'm with I'm
shopping with Rachel I'm like I said you
want some cantaloupe she's like well
don't you win a whole catalogue I'm like
wait wait look around there you know
what the cantaloupes around we got to
get the one that we get you know we
could get cuz it's actually like that so
if you see something you like at the
store right now you gotta just frickin
grab that [ __ ] and go so that's what I
did so we got that you know we got some
other little things some fruits and
vegetables and stuff like that just to
like you know it's also just to be
outside was great but here's my thing
with people outside yo have some social
distancing we in a coronavirus medical
alert pandemic environment so keep your
bodily functions contained if you can so
we in the [ __ ] supermarket and we
like you know got a cart and we're going
and this chick just [ __ ] sneezes just
you know what I mean like not even
trying to like you know hey sneezy McGee
[ __ ] cover your mouth [ __ ] wrong
with you
you know she just with her
and they're giggling and laugh and I'm
like yo you can't just be listen I'm not
saying you know panic anytime somebody
does
they clear their throat you're not
supposed to be like you know you know
all [ __ ] but hey let's act like you know
what's the [ __ ] going on has some
social [ __ ] courtesy can't be
sneezing and coughing and clearing the
throat and like doing [ __ ] with your
hands in these times you've got to be
aware of what the [ __ ] going on
sneezy Magoo is just running around the
store sneezing up a storm not even
acting like and don't be looking around
like and I'm not saying you know you
gotta like you sneeze and you got to be
like oh my god I'm so sorry oh my god
everyone I'm not sick I'm not saying you
got to do that but you also don't got to
look at people like you a gay couple at
the mall holding hands you know looking
for trouble like what who wants to say
something to us because that's how some
people are acting right now they out
here acting like it's totally fine how
the [ __ ] they act and it's like yo
fartin is the only thing and that's not
even acceptable but at least you're the
farts the only bodily function that like
okay if I walk through a fart I'm gonna
be like come on party but I don't want
to walk through somebody's sneeze and
cough so we got to be aware of that you
know
look I just cut you can see we don't
it's nothing shoes we don't know we
don't see how often we touch our face
you know when you got a big nose you
always like on your nose like oh you
know you you always touching your face
that it is hard we gotta like learn to
like do that you know washing your hands
all the time you know which is something
that we should have been doing anyway
right yeah so washing your hands not
touching your face just have some
[ __ ] social etiquette man that's
crazy
you know just walking around then then
we got up to the front of the register
and then she's behind us and I'm just
taking her self [ __ ] are you following
us are you you know and then it's like
you're mine you don't we don't know
anything we don't really know how this
virus works or how its contracted or
like you know we know it's like close
proximity in like boom you could get it
from just touch or whatever I don't even
know and you know so you so you see in
somebody that looks like they have no
regard
human life you know doing whatever they
doing it's like I just was like so
uncomfortable and I just hate that
feeling so we got to help each other out
by like you know acting appropriately
damn [ __ ] is annoying and even when you
go to like two stores and stuff like I
went to this taco place down the street
for me I got a I got a go get outside so
I go for walks you know you go for a
walk taco place to open you can order
take the [ __ ] to go you know I mean but
just dude so he got the gloves on at the
counter you know he got the gloves on
but he got the gloves on taking your
credit card working with your register
but he thinks that the like so he got
the gloves but then he goes over to
where the food is and he's doing some
other [ __ ] and I'm like dude you gotta
have register gloves and then you gotta
have food gloves okay does this [ __ ]
can't [ __ ] mix and match man I don't
know one time I was at Greenblatt's just
deleon on Sunset next to the Laugh
Factory and there was this older woman
in there and she's [ __ ] causing a
ruckus okay just one of these like you
know the world revolves around her like
I wanna try that and and you know just
making a fuss so I'm waiting for my
sandwich okay and she's one of these
like I want to try so they give you they
give you a spoon so to give you a spoon
of whatever she want to try she takes
the spoon she eats it off the spoon that
my sandwich she gets ready it's wrapped
and she they put it on top of the
counter a crazy woman takes her spoon
out of her mouth and then leans her
spoon on my sandwich okay she was
already causing a disturbance for
everybody and she just did it and just
was like you know man
do I look good to do he looked at me I
didn't want to make a scene cuz cuz she
was already making a scene just because
I wanted to be like [ __ ] um did you
just put your mouse spoon on my [ __ ]
sandwich on top here you know you're
making a ruckus about what's going on in
here
but I said all that with a look that I
gave to the guy behind and he looked at
me and he was like don't worry I'm a
rewrap it for you and it's like it's
just like people just that's how this
was before the carniverous can you
imagine now just kill a [ __ ] situation
kicker in her sins I'm like get her you
know I mean we own high alert so I don't
know
and then this did the gun store
situation so I went on a walk I was
walking her in my neighborhood yeah I
didn't realize it was a gun store like
two streets over it looks you like a
mile away because I went on a long walk
so you know get away I'm not just a line
outside this store and I'm like what the
[ __ ] going on in here this is a gun
store I'm like damn what are we arming
for like what are we arming for who you
getting guns for what you gonna do if
you're a gun enthusiast I'm with you if
you somebody this normally you got guns
but I hate to think it like just regular
Joe Schmo has a gun now and they just
like did they go here are wrong noise
and what they gonna fire out their door
like damn let's let's calm down people
calm the [ __ ] down
yeah people I hear crazy whoo all right
I think that might be all the bitching I
have in me for the beginning of this
episode right now you know cuz I just
I'm telling you I'm good I am I am
legitimately this is this is more
difficult than I thought I mean I'm just
I'm not a shut-in type of person like
I've been in my place for 2 or 3 days
you know you come back from a trip I'm
decompressing but to like this kind of
forced forced quarantine forced
isolation it's like weird you started
you know you start looking at your place
like that's not big enough for you start
looking at all the things like this
isn't enough that's not enough you know
the [ __ ] is bizarre and then you you
know don't we everybody's instagramming
live you know luckily I was already
Instagram live in my cooking before this
[ __ ] so but I now I feel like I'm one of
these people I saw I went on Justin
Bieber went live today
so he goes live and he's in one of his
rooms in his big-ass house I'm sure and
he's got a huge wall screen TV movie
room type situation and he's playing
video games so like you don't know this
until he turns on the live he puts to
follow behind him back here and then he
turns
and he's just playing video games and I
was like 35 40 thousand people watching
the back of Justin Bieber's head
watching him play video games and I was
like just looking at it for a while like
even I was like he not doing anything
it's just so fascinating to see like
what is what's happening right now and
you know on the internet just
everybody's live all the time you know
talking about dissing add and like oh so
but hey I'm not a [ __ ] knocking I'm not
necessarily knocking it it's just like
you know it just reminds you of how
isolated we really are you know we
really isolated but just work on your
relationships people make sure you you
know send out love stand send out
affection make sure that you know the
people around you know that you care
about them and it's really difficult
because like my stepfather is about to
get a surgery on he's got like a anyway
it doesn't matter what it is but he's
getting the surgery and you know I have
to he call me like I need you help me
and but my thing is like I don't want to
be around my stepfather and my mom
they're of that age that they can get
super sick so it's really a catch-22 I'm
not telling him like maybe you should be
scheduled or we should make other
arrangements with like some sort of
medical or professional arrangements
like like the they come pick you up
because I just don't want to risk it
I've been on planes a bit I was in
Chattanooga you know my girl still works
and she comes you know here so I'm like
damn you know you know you don't even
know I don't feel sick I don't feel like
I have any symptoms or anything like
that but you see on the internet there
are people who are like they look fine
and the next thing you know boom they
they have it so I just didn't want to
risk it you know I started just
quarantine and I just want to be like
let me be that 14 15 20 days pass where
I don't feel like I have anything and
then I'll be like okay I'll go from here
straight to my parents to see how they
are but damn and it's tough because my
mom she's like you know she's got this
dementia so like I just talked to her
today I know she
understands because she's like whoa I
haven't been outside and it's everywhere
so cuz the news my stepfather's keeping
the news online look look we can't go
outside cuz she wants to like oh I think
it'll be fine tomorrow and then you know
it's like oh she wants to go out so it's
like you know just worrying about that
it's just like a nightmare so for all
those people out there who have like
we're all worried about our parents if
you're of a certain age if your 30s 40s
you worried about your parents because
your parents are of a age that they are
more susceptible to getting this and
having complications so be safe out
there you know be safe don't don't don't
risk it cuz cuz imagine the guilt of
feeling like you got your parents sick
and then something happens to them ah
who wants to deal with that you know
what I mean I just hope we get back to
normal sometime soon
but anyways that's what I wanted to just
a beginning part of this is just have
some social etiquette that's all we got
to have virus pandemic etiquette
pandemic etiquette we gotta had that
okay so clean your hands cover your
mouth keep your distance and all you
people still working in food service and
all that kind of stuff be aware of what
you're doing because you realize we
weren't worrying about that [ __ ] at all
you know you know it's like I realized
when I was in Tennessee like I was gonna
pay with my credit card and the girl was
like oh I'm not gonna touch your credit
card can you slide it yourself and turn
the screen around let me slide it and I
was like damn then I looked at my credit
card and I was like oh that's right so
many people touched your credit card so
many times like how many times a year I
pulled your credit card out of your
wallet and you're like trying to get
something and then you put your credit
card in your mouth on your lips to hold
it and then you like do something or
some [ __ ] like that you know I don't I
don't know if you did I've done that a
couple times done that before I could
remember the time I was a where's my you
know oh you know you think about you've
touched your credit card it's sliding in
between this thing that there's other
[ __ ] there however many people have
touched their credit cards in there was
so clean your credit cards clean your
wallet and clean things that you know
have been out and
like you've touched before like I clean
knees I have cleaned the mics you know
cuz when I finally if people want to
come over to do my podcast I'm still
happy to have you know certain people
that I know come over but it's like you
know I'm saying later when it's like
when this is calmed down more you know
but like other than that it's like think
of all the things that you touch that
have been out in public and it's like
your wallet your phone and then like
think about like even at a hotel they
talk about some of the dirtiest things
or the phone and the remote control so
like when's the last time you wipe down
your remote control you know what was it
before the pandemic because we were
still taken sometimes have you just come
home didn't even wash your hands didn't
do [ __ ] plop down on the couch and then
take turned on the TV so you had the day
yo de funk is on that remote control so
wipe down your remote controls everybody
sure I've done everything but I'm just
started thinking to the things that you
go damn I've brought the public out into
the onto this thing or if like so like
wipe your credit cards and your wallet
and your purse and like think your keys
and like that kind of stuff you know and
then you think about if you're in your
car your steering wheel and like your
car area that you're always touching and
like it's a nightmare to Hollett imagine
that this is our new way of life for
like a year where we're just constantly
like boom boom boom well maybe that'll
maybe that'll be better we maybe it'll
we'll learn and pick up like better
habits you don't I mean maybe we'll have
better habits but I don't know but we'll
see this is another quick bonus episode
for the week man and I'm glad you guys
are listening and I'm gonna keep making
content keep talking to y'all I want to
do one more this week too so but for
that one I like some questions so I'm
gonna put up an Instagram post one of
those question posts or you could send
me an email just like in the subject
line just put a bonus questions bonus
question and then I'm gonna start answer
answering some questions and talk about
some things for the next episode of the
week so this one I think I'm putting
this one out Wednesday so today's
Wednesday though when this is out and
please you send me your comments and
send me your questions and
um you know let's continue to interact
and have some fun but so now what I did
was I set up my system I figured it out
and I was able to Skype a couple of my
friends i Skyped more than a couple but
like the sound is I'm still working out
the kinks in the sound you know the
kinks I was working out in the sound of
my [ __ ] podcast and look how long it
took me I was like and there's still a
little bit of an echo on this [ __ ] but
I'm starting to figure out what it's
about it's about the output source so
I'm figuring that [ __ ] out so the sound
on this next section of the podcast is
gonna be a little wonky but I'm working
this [ __ ] out I don't need your dumb ass
comments I got it
okay I know alright so I called a couple
of people and here's some Skype calls
from a few of my friends and just just
to check in with them and see how
they're doing so I hope you enjoy okay
everybody and you know we're back back
again skyping with Griffin call another
one of my friends one of my good buddies
mr. mister
[Laughter]
forget gone crazy yesterday it was like
a hint of depression but it went it
passed a really awesome now I don't just
felt like depressed I never I never feel
depressed so I can tell when it happens
that's what depression feels like well
then it it went away yeah I know what
you mean it's like I've been I've been
feeling that way too I've been feeling
like like there's been times I've been
at my house for two days in a row not
doing anything just sitting around but
there's something about being forced to
sit around that it's making it different
you know what I'm saying is that what
you're kind of feeling I hope that's
what it was I don't know what it was I
it's it's it's not a feeling that I'm
used to and I couldn't exactly pinpoint
you know maybe maybe it's some of the
drugs I've done has affected me
chemically I don't know but you know
nuts if hopefully yeah oh please just
some [ __ ] that wall
come back I won't last yeah yeah just I
didn't feel like all this social
distance and it's like you like you
you've called me like more than you've
ever called just you know we just be
randomly calling people like what you
doin oh you've called me back more than
you call I know it's weird like Bobby's
called me a few times it's like yeah
it's just like I call him fit my
callback from them yeah hey Zeus trail
call me you know I'm glad you did call
cuz like you know his mom also has
dementia so like we you know he was just
can't reaching out like that and I was
like oh man thanks for reaching out you
know but if you so you have you probably
haven't had any problem at the grocery
store getting your nasty-ass vegan food
bro I mean I shop at Whole Foods and
Trader Joe's right uh-huh but I live
half a block from Thai town so there's a
Asian or Thai supermarket that's in the
cut on Hollywood Boulevard
and then Saturday when I got back into
town I saw I just it just popped in my
mind said don't forget that place go
there and I went here and there were no
lines and there was a lot of [ __ ] like
they have first of all it's it's weird
because it has the bulk size vegan meats
when I say you got pepper steak Egan
chicken nuggets vegan vegan fish kung
pao chicken
like any type like there's a restaurant
so just broccoli basically is what they
are it's like the process version of
vegan types of chicken and and in bulk
and they are vegan shrimp you know so I
just bought a bunch of those and I just
eat it with my quinoa or my wild rice
and my beans and just I'll make a pot of
rice last week and I ate that I just
kept on switching the meat substitutes
with it you know
and this you know I'm lucky it's there I
can go back there if I want to but I've
been in the crib man I'm not going out
yeah
aye aye I like to go for walks that's
something I haven't been doing and I've
been cooking you know I've been cooking
on Instagram you know but I've been
swimming it's really not for Instagram
it's like I'm cooking cuz that's how I
eat and I find myself like you know I'm
not spending as much money I don't want
to and I'm also like I found myself
slimming down because I'm eating like
you know a proper meal and then I'm
gonna snacking and all this kind of
stuff so you know I don't know I mean
just just just just quarantine and the
virus is like it's terrible but it's
doing wonders for the environment it's
not all bad we needed it to slow down
anyway like I wanted to start cooking
and I just couldn't find the time and
then now I'm like cooking every day yes
I don't want to I don't want to you know
I appreciate like all their help the
people out there working and cooking and
doing making takeout meals for people
pick up and get but I don't know if they
got it so I'm just gonna be cautious I'm
just gonna cook about if I'm in I'm in
so I'm just cooking myself and then it
takes up some of the time of the day to
cook myself you know just it's just
weird I don't know if like you know part
of me wants to feel like it's an
overreaction but then the other part of
me feels like you know cuz I don't I
feel like there's not enough information
there's a lot of misinformation you
noticing you want me explain it to you
yeah yeah give it to me all right so
this is what happened first they came
out and said the thing was the flu
because it kind of is but it it's an E
and it might be just as deadly as the
flu but one thing it is it's more
contagious than the flu you can catch it
airborne
if you
if you touch something its lives on
surfaces right so then you have that
that now there's 400 well there's 350
million people in America there's only 1
million hospital beds
there's only 45,000 intensive care units
so if if even if let's let's play the
number game even if 10% of the
population got it in a serious way right
when the medical system will be
overwhelmed with cases and people who
wouldn't die if they were treated will
die because they won't be able to get
treated so that's how something that's
not as deadly becomes deadly so and it's
hard for people to make the 180 from
this being a flu right as serious as it
is when they were told in the first
place it's just a flu but yeah but it's
a numbers game it's just you there's not
that many respirators in this country
right you know it's like so I think I
felt the same I knew exactly what you're
saying and I'm trying to wrap my brain
around it in the same way I feel like if
they have enough tests to go around then
they'd be able to like casually be like
ok oh you know first if you feel like
you're sick stay at home in quarantine
if it's too much then you go to the
hospital or it should be a thing where
we could just grab the test at CVS and
be like you know man turns out I got
come on I got to go home once it's right
once it's to that level then we'll be
able to like return to normal life but I
hear what you're saying it's like if
even if 10 million people got sick all
at once just would be a situation yeah
like like 10 million people got it more
than half of that are gonna die because
like if they got it seriously like the
serious version they've only ten million
people of the 350 million people in
America got the serious version of this
more than half of them would probably
die maybe more
because there is no way to treat them
yeah not I mean so yeah the numbers way
too scary you do
yeah you welcome to America that's why
you should say your ass is inside yeah
everybody's out there like Runyon Canyon
is packed and it's like stay inside man
like the COS here is another thing a lot
of people are worried about how am I
gonna pay my rent so I gotta go out and
make money but if you go out and make
money this week and and last week then
they're gonna have to do this [ __ ] again
and then if you go out that week they're
gonna have to do this [ __ ] again so the
N is gonna be more weeks of not making
money until everybody does it until it's
done right and we can clear it out the
country you feel me so the longer you
you might be like listen you could
probably survive two weeks of no money
but if you keep [ __ ] this up you
ain't gonna survive
six weeks of no money eight weeks of no
money ten weeks of no money the
economy's not gonna come back people are
gonna die some of them your loved ones
so just chill just just chill man like
listen people like I talked to somebody
today they worried about they bills that
you those bills will still be there
after this you know always behind on
your payments so why you trippin now
well that's a that's the message I think
that's a great message I'm glad you
handling it the way you are so we
intellectualizing it and trying to like
really figure it out and really
understand yeah yeah I think there's a
lot of misinformation out there and it's
like people just don't understand it
Yuki it's not like you know you go to
the website a website and go what is
kurono and they just it doesn't explain
it it doesn't give you people enough
peace of mind to be like okay I think I
get what's going on and why I need to
stay inside so you know but the overall
message stay inside don't spread this we
don't have enough hospital beds we don't
have enough resources if everybody got
it at the same time yeah exactly people
who who wouldn't normally die from this
flu will die and that's just math period
well there it is y'all that's Ian
Edwards you know we gonna keep checking
in with in you
throughout throughout this whole thought
this whole thing because ain't nothing
else to do this is my motto my corona
motto is I ain't going out there and it
ain't coming in D word key word is that
means I got some wisdom and they know
what the [ __ ] they talk about there's a
reason why they become old black
grandmas well I appreciate it man thanks
I'm gonna call and you know we'll
continue on and in the future now I'll
talk to you again and so that's in their
words everybody let's hope you stay safe
okay
here's another one of my friends let's
check in and see how mr. Jeff Ross is
doing Jeff how you doing buddy you know
living the quarantine life Jeff is like
an 85 year old man he can't figure out
how to work the Skype so yeah now you're
cutting your head off I'm up here on the
space shuttle just want to say hi to my
family will you move the camera up a
little bit see you know how to do
technology right right there perfect
there you there he is everybody's area
so what do you what have you been doing
have you been holding up with this
quarantine I've been watching Tiger King
on Netflix have you seen that show no I
have it everybody's talking about that
is that is that gonna better a better
making a murderer is that what it's
about it's so it's just this group of
crazy big cat collectors who really hate
each other and it chronicles them all
basically trying to kill each other but
I couldn't believe it it's really cool I
think you'd like it
I'm gonna check that out what else have
you been watching i watch a lot of West
Wing I love that show it makes me feel
good that twelve seasons are on Netflix
it goes all in
like 20 years when presidents used to be
really smart and regal Jeb Bartlet
what's-his-face
Charlie Sheen's dead what's-his-name
yeah
Martin Sheen plays the president and
he's like the smartest guy in the world
you know it's funny I find myself trying
to catch up on like III go let me watch
a show that everybody was talking about
that I've never watched before so I'm
trying to find like what those shows are
you know like Wes I never watched West
Wing so you make me want to like I mean
get into that well I know you like to
talk about politics sometimes in a
stand-up and this is is I learned a lot
about politics watching just them the
stories and Sorkin writes it and it has
a lot of big political columnist are the
consultants on the show so I've been
enjoying that one and I watched some old
ones like I've been watching mash I've
been watching the Hogan's Heroes I'm
like a big kid up here man masses on
Hulu right now I know
mash is great it's funny how that show
holds up those old show good man they
don't even make shows that edgy anymore
I don't think they even could I don't
know if I don't think I don't think a
show like mash could be on the air right
now what do you think I don't think so
there's too much it's too real about war
and stuff everybody's I don't know I'm
glad to see you because I literally just
took an hour walk and I was listening to
the news on podcasts and stuff and I
never get like this I'm always positive
but I'm [ __ ] pissed off like the
Republicans and Democrats are arguing
over simulus package for the people and
I'm like why is the Senate whose slowest
hell all the time always divided why are
they in charge of emergencies it seems
like the worst idea this [ __ ] should
have been planned by a different part of
the government a long time ago I can't
believe that this is the politics during
the pandemic I know these guys are
pretending it's a hoax and then they get
the disease it's like we're watching a
bed a bad movie and every time I see
like all those guys standing up at a
press conference I go where's the social
distance like they're all [ __ ] crazy
they're all standing together like that
you just go like are you guys really
taking taking all this serious then it's
like I could it doesn't make any sense
man but then we're in an election year
too so that's a tough part too right
we're in an election like how are we
gonna do that like I like talked about
suppressing the vote they're gonna have
to make it they're gonna the who's gonna
go vote with those germs I know those
people those Jill Biden voters they're
all gonna die a corona virus this is
[ __ ] crazy yeah you feel I feel like
you're a little stir crazy like how have
you been holding up I was fine until
today everything started to [ __ ] get
to me a little bit today oh really
Wow other than the first week everyone's
neighbourly you know you're eating at
home it's fun it's cute you said to get
a little nuts like even the dog
where is she's right here I normally she
can hang she loves getting a little walk
a little pet here and there but I've
been around so much that she's spoiled
and today I opened the door and she just
ran out the door and [ __ ] almost
killed some neighbor's dog for no reason
yeah man I'm feeling it I'm feeling it
too man I've been talking to some other
people I just feel like I feel
stir-crazy I feel like and then I'm like
you know then you find yourself fighting
with your loved ones because you don't
normally spend complete 24 hours with oh
my god so like I found myself like I was
fighting with my girl it's just like I'm
telling myself you know what it is I
find that because I don't have that
comedy outlet anymore that like you know
we go to the store we got that 15
minutes to just let out all of our
whatever that is and then when we go
back to normal people all that [ __ ] is
gone so now it's like it's still in me
like I need to talk well I am a
particularly bad cuz I'm an insult comic
so I start roasting my girl roast in the
[ __ ] inanimate objects around the
house
the people get mad at me I can't be
making I can't be roasting Amazon guy
what he shows that mean actually she's
that actually be hilarious like you you
should have a gayest set up you know
so the Susy opens the door it's like
this right there you're like the fattest
GrubHub delivery guy by the way I got 2
mystery tacos delivered from Chipotle
today I didn't order them them they were
outside so either someone sent me some
and didn't write a note what are they
you trust in random I didn't need it
just tacos at your door dude yeah you
threw them away around and I put them in
the fridge my buddy took my buddy Chris
dropped off [ __ ] toilet paper with
some birthday hat on it no just a party
a party roll so now I guess I'm good
till tomorrow a couple months ago this
company this booty wipes company that's
the name of the company booty wipes so
they uh they sent me like a big box of
likes he's like you know one one-shot
booty box I'm so glad I have them right
now they're coming in handy but I have
like one of those like bootie washer
things too though I'm glad you're you're
keeping your hygiene up don't you have
to I'm washing my hands more than I ever
have before
dude I'm not even shale and I haven't
put my island and water broto at all
hang out my balls okay really we can
talk about your balls go ahead this here
about your ball right let's tell you
about your blue/white [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no wonder your girls Mattia you went
from Fashion Week to Fashion Week this
is what we should do we gotta call our
comic friends talking [ __ ] so we could
go back to our girls and be like baby I
love you that's exactly it
how much money have you lost so far
don't even get me started man it's crazy
right yeah I could even if I could even
afford the upgrade and
is the last show I'm gonna do in a long
time I just did this show in my last
show was in the comedy catch in
Chattanooga oh yeah it was just a
nightmare
you know people people said 560 tomorrow
they came because this was like right
before it was like three days before it
was everybody stay home last two
weekends ago those two weekends ago so
you know it was cool you know but I just
thought you felt something in the air
though you know what I mean you feel you
felt the weirdness I don't even walk
even when I take a walk I walk around my
neighborhood and you see somebody coming
and I find myself being like well let me
walk across walk into the street you
know we're trying to keep distance
because I just people they're not being
polite about their bodily functions I
feel like you know I just walked down
Ventura Boulevard
with the dog and the only people on the
street are crazy people drugged people
looking for drugs and weirdos with with
you know bikes that have like a week's
supply of food on them yes worried about
the homeless problem in LA what are they
doing self quarantine even working out
is that even something that they're even
thinking about that's 60,000 people
right there that these shelters on the
streets is so scary man yeah it's weird
it's weird times man
that's why I always said that's why I
always say [ __ ] the poor oh is that what
are you yeah you know my [ __ ] the poor
merch is not selling well lately I don't
know what's going on I'm gonna doomsday
[ __ ] didn't you know I could tell man
you're not yourself I must go to my dog
knowing that like in two months she's
that she's cute but two months she'll be
[ __ ] and surviving by eating my
cadaver oh I know I did have you did you
stock up what did you did you what do
you do are you cooking at home are you
ordering out all the time what are you
doing I've been eating a lot of pasta
and through
I got some stuff I'm trying to stock up
I ordered a fancy dinner date night last
night after two weeks I was like I need
something good so we let heard Craig's
fancy restaurant delivered and that was
nice but my girl mitt made breakfast
made some egg salad and we're making do
yeah she you guys both just locked in
had you just been locked in for like
this whole time right now there's like
yeah yeah luckily I got a yard and and I
can go outside with the dog and walk
around you know my buddy is Seth Green
the actor producer and he lives
um you've been in my house so that
defense defense below me assess fence
weight so it was his brother-in-law's
birthday so we had a little party about
five six of us went up to the fence we
smoked smoked our own joints and I did a
social distance birthday for an hour
sitting in the basically sitting in the
in the yard
esta this table what about always
thinking about what about those people
that had weddings planned you know
people that have you know six months out
they had just wedding they had their
march/april wedding or bar mitzvahs and
like all these kind of like things that
just kind of shut down or you're dead
flick special oh [ __ ] that's right huh
close to be shooting in a few weeks Wow
well it could be it could be worse it
could it could now look at me I'm on the
Eric Griffin [ __ ] hostage video what
is it it takes a pandemic for you to
like come on the park this is this looks
like this looks like I'm pleading for my
safety with house below please well then
give me his apples you know let this
happen go right ahead I could tell you
need this
anybody ever been on a live skype
interview and just taken her phone and
just threw it over everyone's like just
the worst net like it's not like they're
taking our phones away you know it was
like we're kind of a clip for this [ __ ]
Skype and FaceTime and Netflix and
Internet we all kind of are know how to
be on our own like you know you're old
enough to know what it was like to be a
comedian before the Internet I don't
know if you were doing it back then but
it was lonely you went on the road with
your book and if you found you couldn't
even make calls out of the hotel it's
expensive so you had a beeper you had to
go to a payphone like you were low I
know what it's like to be lonely so this
is this is a treat I get to talk to my
friends you know this part of it I have
to at least acknowledge we are living in
the perfect time where all this to go
down you know I say yes and no I talked
about this earlier it's just like I feel
like we think that we want social
distance anyway with our snapchats in
are and how we text and don't call
people but right now I feel like
everybody stir-crazy I feel like we're
starving for like human interaction you
know and this isn't enough like it's not
enough you know what I mean we touched
me when you touch me that's thank you I
went to 7-Eleven yesterday I was so
bored I got was hot I'd been walking the
dog when all that adventure all sweating
if I go into 7-eleven there's no one in
there but two cops on my head I get a
bottle of water I don't touch anything
but I get a cold bottle of water I get
to the counter and I forgot my wallet
I've no cash so I'm like I'm like two
miles from home no money it's hot out
you wanna you walk two miles downhill
downhill and I had to walk back up the
hill and I asked to go please can I have
the ones like no I got a cup of water
he's like alright so now I'm taking an
open cup of Corona water from the
7-eleven cashier and I'm like this is it
this is how you get it do you see
be like super paranoid early I'm
surprised at you even cuz effort when
this first happened I called you - did
you - podcast and you were like I can't
I can't go I can't be near people and
now you're like you know you're drinking
out of an open profit and for him I'm
like yeah I don't know I think it my
immunities build-up or my guts or I
think I mean or also I'm gonna sign my
fate you know I mean yeah yeah I feel
you
I'm worried about my parents at your
house your parents are your parents
alive what's up with your you know they
died a long time ago so I'm one of the
lucky ones I don't have to worry about
them yeah I'm worried about my parents
my mom's got dementia so it's like weird
to like you know she doesn't give me
sorta she sort of gets it but then what
it doesn't get it you know so I have to
like you not to keep every day I got to
get the news you can't go out you know
cuz he wants to go to her you know a
relative's house that's not alive you
know what I mean
oh boy you know it's nowhere around
where she is but she thinks it's down
the street you know so the oh my
goodness she's okay yeah my stepdads
with her so it's like he's got to go get
surgery yeah he's got like a thing on
his nose he's trying to get removed and
he already had the surgery scheduled so
now I gotta go I gotta make sure she's
okay so it's like and I'm for worried
like I've been on the road I'm fine I
don't feel sick or anything like that
but you know how you worry when we
travel that much wrong yes yeah you know
we don't know I just think I think
comics have like a heavy immune system I
think just because of like being on
dirty Mike's and like you know dirty
beds yeah yeah yeah we've built up a
tolerance but I'm still worried my main
worry about is like I don't want to have
something that I could pass on
unknowingly to my freaking parents scary
you know you can't see them it makes you
really appreciate me no physical contact
and all the good times
I know because even when they're talking
about like these elderly people that get
it they isolate them and then they have
to die alone like how [ __ ] brutal is
this man then they do the beat or you
can't even visit them you know you can't
do you know they just have to hopefully
they survive if they don't you're like
you know you can look through that
little window like oh my goodness would
be terrible
oh my goodness
I know I don't know why we shouldn't
meet the first to get all morbid but we
really should be cheering people I know
we should be cheering people up on the
bright side no more three ways on
pornhub because wait if you can keep
going you know if they're not worried
about AIDS herpes crabs you know no you
know who's making all the money is the
webcam girls yeah how they were making
all the money
anyways David tell Tommy on my podcast
he called yesterday
he's like the webcam girls are making
all the money why not
and they're doing in Vegas they're doing
drive-by lap dances like you can watch
from your car for a hundred bucks
who the [ __ ] is that morning wait do so
is your window rolled out and they just
like I don't know and stuff on your car
can you remember what do you imagine
Vegas is shut down like I wonder what
that looks like right now like what does
that look like the strip is just empty
have you even seen a picture of it no
but I have I had a buddy text me some
pictures yesterday from Times Square in
New York and it was very eerie oh man
you know how you were saying you look
you have a big house you have a big
beautiful house you know I have this I'm
in like a town house you know it's I
have space but thank you imagine being
in New York and living in some little
you know our apartments are so little
there some of them I mean that must be
crazy
New Yorkers are stir-crazy a lot of them
are trying to get out get out to the
suburbs and stay with family but that's
scary too you know yeah well well
luckily they say it's only another like
six months make you imagine like like
when are we gonna get back on stage like
what's your thoughts like when do you
think we're gonna get back on stage
I can't it's gotta be by the by this by
the end of the summer right I don't know
I don't know you know I took a break
about a year and a half ago to make sure
I could you see if I needed comedy or
this comedy there's an old mayor do I
own it and I took a break and I felt
good to take a break so even though I'm
supposed to be on tour right now and the
bulk of my
years been cut off I like knowing that I
could stop and be okay you know that I
don't get the itch too bad I feel you
man I'm feeling it I feel I didn't
realize how like a dick being and how
much that is the thing that I did like
you know three four times a week we're
at the Comedy Store the last time
through the improv you know wherever we
just know we're gonna have like shows
and get that that that rush to not have
that I didn't I didn't think it would be
a thing but I'm realizing it is yeah it
is a thing man and you got to try to
channel it into some other thing you
know it's a good time to write something
else or you know even as simple as
downloading in your brain other
influences different movies that you
always want to see or I know dare I say
read a book or learn an instrument just
just write a love letter to something
that you never thought you would have
time to do and you'll wind up you'll
wind up making the most out of it I'm a
big silver lining this guy like today
was rough and I'm a little baddie today
but I always try to see some silver
lining in this kind of stuff I feel you
I know what you're saying I'm trying to
be that way too I find myself meditating
at night just when I'm feeling because
that night is when I start to feel I'm
going to bed I'm starting to feel like
oh my god what's gonna happen tomorrow
and I start to like spiral and then I
just turn on one of these sleep
meditations that I have and then you
know you just think you do your
meditation breath and you just go okay
you know what it's gonna be fine
tomorrow I'm gonna be okay oh that's
good yeah so I do recommend that kind of
stuff there's so many of you just going
YouTube it's like any of those things
that like sleep meditation and a guided
meditation to go to sleep those are
pretty good because they they get you in
tune with your body like they'll be like
you know feel your hands and feel your
feet and your inner you know then you
when you when it's done you're like oh
[ __ ] I'm actually not thinking about my
impending death Wow meditation into into
the thing yeah man just play like you
know guided sleep meditation and you'll
be surprised how how helpful it'll be I
feel like we just made a sleep
meditation video yeah I'm walking into
my office to find a joint at least some
pod stores haven't closed Oh that'll be
all again if it's oh if you lose the
internet and pot you're done I mean that
would be that would be crazy but we're
survivors Americans are survivors men
you know tonight I'll let it goes a
minute in there to where I was like am I
ever gonna work again and then and then
you go you know what it almost makes it
people appreciate comedy even more
comeback because they haven't seen you
and been cooped up they want to see a
live show that perspectives were in that
you know people [ __ ] cancelling
comics take it on can't like then you
know and and and people misses a little
bit yeah it's just like sports - I miss
sports
- men I really miss sports I miss like
just the the Kyle I listen to those like
sports debate shows every single day and
like yeah they're still going and
they're still talking about footballs if
that's gonna happen so like I think it's
all wishful thinking because I don't
really think the NFL's gonna go on
either you know when it comes but for
right now they're acting like it is and
it's just it's so weird it's weird it's
really weird that's why you don't know
what's gonna take off what's gonna come
back the late-night posts are even doing
there shows remotely so no one's really
getting a chance to even miss them and
and I think it's good that the comedians
are staying on their podcast and stuff
cuz I mean you don't want to feel
isolated as people who definitely
who rely on comedy to get through their
[ __ ] day at least you know you're in
your nice house whatever but like some
people they would go to school to get
away from abusive parents I had about
like second nagging abusive husbands
wives who knows right right I think a
lot of people are really like need
something to put into their ears and get
a little mental vacation even if they
can't go on a physical no III appreciate
that I appreciate that you think like
that I think that's I think everybody
out there is like I think this is also a
time to connect I think it's important
to like call loved ones or even just
friends you haven't talked to in a while
because look we're here we're home we're
not doing [ __ ] you know I was like when
I call somebody now they don't answer I
go okay you purposely that's a good
point man you know everybody's home well
this is a good one man I appreciate you
taking the call you know oh don't start
what you can't finish
we should do it again you know a couple
more weeks just say I'm just checking in
I think this is good content for people
that so we can see like here's what
we're thinking - we're normal we have
the same thought processes we got the
same fears we get the same you know this
the same anxiety that everybody else has
and I think it's okay to feel those
things I think you're right
I think you're absolutely right that's
why I'm gonna burn my arm just for no
reason
all right everybody this has been Ross
signing off coming on man I appreciate
you coming on and Griffin Griffin
everybody all right man we'll talk soon
all right all right I take care and
there it is y'all that was it that was
Ian Edwards and a good old buddy Jeff
Ross so I hope you enjoyed that and I'm
gonna have more of those and I hope you
enjoyed the you know this episode of yo
favorite podcast you know the name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you Friday
[Music]